well
biden is furious that he's trailing
trump in the polls erupted over being
kept out of the loop on baby formula and
is trying to avoid being compared to
jimmy carter no he's like worse than
jimmy carter
don't worry joey won't compare you to
there you go notice they they didn't
have to keep him out of loop on like
adult diapers right he knows what those
numbers are
yeah he's like what's the stock on adult
diapers man well there's actually some
very interesting comparisons to jimmy
carter's administration to the biden
administration especially to what
happened in the 1970s especially with
what happened geopolitically uh with a
lot of very similar troubles that people
had to deal with then that people are
also dealing with now um and i think
especially if you look at the baby
formula shortage another problem of too
big government it's wic program it's
over production it's over reliance on
one particular corporation that probably
has ties to the government
again a lot of these problems go
directly towards the central planners
that think that they could control every
aspect of your existence and because
they do they make a lot of problems for
you i think these problems are
deliberate and they're only going to get
worse from here you guys want trump to
run again
man i kind of do because i'm not so
convinced desantis is going to clean
house you know so like a couple months
ago i was saying i would prefer desantis
because he's he's younger he's he's got
more tact and everything but just with
how crazy things are getting i'm kind of
like
i think desantis would get in and try
and hold on
i think trump will get in and just clean
house he's going to fire everybody i
have i i have the opposite approach i
have no trust in trump at all i think he
was totally infiltrated and totally
acted for the deep state and and made
the situation worse for a lot of people
operation warp speed uh is is one of the
hugest scan and
so much uh scams that were running on
the american people so many mistakes
that's just my perspective i just 2024
is gonna be fascinating because come on
do you think
kamala harris because bine's not running
again right
no way there's no way there's no
but hopefully pretend he is they would
have to announce within the next few
months if that's the case because they
got to start lining up the primary pool
for next year yeah but you don't think
they're so identity obsessed you don't
really think democrats would allow
anyone to challenge kamala harris do you
i don't you look at you look at her poll
numbers she is extremely unlikable but
who wants to be the democrat who tries
to tries to push out a woman of color
so no here's a question though it
depends on whether the mainstream media
feels in the dnc feels that this
candidate who's running against kamala
is useful to them because if that's the
case then all the horrible things kamala
has said and done are going to be fair
game and the media is going to allow
people to discuss them i i see maybe
even michelle obama stacey abrams who's
a bilderberg member by the way i see all
of them making prominent moves uh in
this buddha judge i think he's also
going to be another prominent individual
that they're propping up here as well uh
so i think we're gonna keep an eye on
all of them but um i i i think the
united states is a sinking ship and i
don't know who would want to want the
job at this at this juncture because
you're literally going to be in charge
of something that's
that that people are not going to be
happy with in the in the near future
look i mean if pete buddha judge can
give birth he can save the country
pete buddha judge doesn't have the x
factor he doesn't no no gavin newsom
looks like a mannequin oh not gavin
newsom he looks like he's he's michelle
obama but she she's like apparently
never going to do it washington governor
jay inslee he got like one percent the
first time around right
whitmore she's very popular in michigan
and
and that california yeah
california guy what's his name that eats
at that very fancy restaurant yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that guy no
he looks like a mannequin yeah he does
he's very pointy botox sharp just looks
like it's made of plastic booty judge
has a lot of cia connections so i i
still see him being promoted and
prompted up and i think he's going to be
a contender at least he can string a
sentence together yeah well he's yummy
and trendy and you know
he has all the he he doesn't have the x
factor but but i do see him uh being
promoted prominently in the next
upcoming election that's how i just see
it sorry i derailed the conversation no
no no that's fair point um it's fine
we're
we're in a huge mess with this
administration and who's gonna come
clean up the pieces absolutely no one
and you need to be personally
responsible for yourself in my opinion
my perspective and i might be wrong and
it's okay if i'm wrong is that
if you believe a politician is going to
help you out you have victim mentality
um no one's going to help you out no
one's going to come and save you someone
you yourself is going to help us and it
is alexandria ocasio-cortez
aoc is criticizing democrats refusal to
use the word latinx despite divide over
the term many democrats worry the term
latinx alienates voters of latin
american descent
stop don't stop keep keep keep on going
tell them all to keep saying it please
please your advocacy is so important
helping republicans win in in the
midterms didn't you just come out as
native american yes yes yep nope just uh
she's trans racial
so there's the thing about the tanks
i've said this before part of the reason
the left feels it's so important for
folks to start using this phrase is
because to name a person or group of
people is to assert ownership over them
and that is how they view the hispanic
community they believe that they're
their owners and handlers just like they
feel they're the owners and handlers of
every single other minority group they
claim to speak for now the latino
community does not use this phrase they
don't like that phrase the polling has
made it perfectly clear but these
leftist colonists are going to do every
single thing they can to force their
bizarre gender ideology onto this
culture i think they know that they have
to work their way in there and really
destroy
the hispanic understanding of family
life by subverting their understanding
of gender roles because they know that
given the
catholic culture of many of these
nations
they are likely to be more socially
conservative in the future and they
could even become republican voters
i think that's the fear so they need to
do every single thing they can now to
subvert that culture as much as possible
that's what this term is well you look
at destroy their understanding of sexual
relationships destroy their
understanding of the differences between
men and women you look at south texas
and uh
things are not looking good for
democrats latino voters are voting
republican you look at florida
yeah november's gonna be wild do you
think that i mean like seriously when um
you know churches get torched or when
the holy mass is interrupted over row
being overturned how do you think a
mexican catholic feels about that like
how do you think that voter bloc is
going to respond they they are going to
do everything they can to strip these
cultures of their identity
it's going to be interesting i mean
there's going i think there's going to
be a lot of surprises before november um
i i think there's a lot of more
instability than we even realize right
now i think financially this is going to
be the bigger kind of picture here
that's going to affect a lot of people's
decisions especially at the voting uh
booth but
it it's it's really just just
fascinating that there's so many
problems there there's so many things
going wrong but but we're talking about
latinx like that's just i told you this
is just crazy alex is going to be lit
august oh yeah yeah the the uh the fall
so we're going to be getting into the
fall harvest season so we're going to be
running low on food there's not going to
be new food or it's going to be
seriously depleted because of the lack
of fertile fertilizer in spring there's
going to be diesel shortages no diesel
means even if they have the food they
can't bring it to you it's going to be
10 bucks a gallon in california and
probably in a bunch of other places
we're about to break five dollars a
gallon as it is
but uh hopefully aoc keeps criticizing
democrats who don't say the word the
thinks yeah keep it up
maybe tim we could solve all these
problems by calling people electronics
you know maybe everything's gonna be
good
latinx i don't even know how to
pronounce it
i don't even care how to pronounce it
like latino latina latinx i wanna make
sure i pronounce it correctly you know i
just wanna make sure you don't
we had a progressive on this show
recently and when i asked him why the
green new deal had a bunch of stuff like
free college for marginalized people and
health care he's like because that's
who's affected first and i'm like that
doesn't solve anything having to do with
the climate crisis
it's like we want to solve climate
change so we're going to give college to
to minorities i'm like
what does that do about carbon emissions
nothing but you can't point that out
because then you're racist you're racist
i guess
you're racist against the latinx
there was a meme i saw and it said
when gas prices go up they should like a
wind turbine and it's like the price for
running the wind turbine didn't and then
i responded with like they used
petroleum-based lubricants
like what do you what do you think what
are you talking about
of course the prices went up the price
for everything goes up
i don't know what that what what they're
doing i can only say this the one thing
that it seems to be is that the country
is being gutted and burned to the ground
deliberately on purpose not by accident
they try to make it look like it's an
accident they're like oh no it's just
some competency well i mean the actions
they take that are burning the country
down are completely deliberate
absolutely but i would i would assume
the la the path to hell is paved with
good intentions absolutely i think
there's an element of that as well but i
think there's also just organizations
being like well let's let's make these
people believe that they're doing the
right thing let's let's push this agenda
here let's let's let's actually you know
rearrange things in a way that's going
to work out for our personal benefit so
i do see people kind of waiting behind
the scenes pushing a lot of these
agendas and narratives that do play a
bigger role that we don't even realize
immediately but then later down the line
we're like hey we're looking around like
hey there's only bugs to eat here hey we
only have a pod hey we only have a vr
headset hey hey we can't go out of our
house we don't have a car we can't
afford a car we can't even drive a car
um
so i do see this kind of larger element
that we're slowly creeping into which is
a technocratic nightmare and i think
it's worth calling out i i think the
this news especially with elon musk and
twitter is a lot bigger than we even
realized i think there's a lot on the
line here um and it's and it's let's
just say it's not a boring time to be
alive it's very interesting and uh i i
think it's only going to get a lot more
interesting
there's this point you made earlier tim
that the road to hell is paved with good
intentions and in many ways that's true
but you know bad intentions don't pave
the road to heaven and we do live in a
culture unfortunately where many of
those at the top really do have very bad
intentions and it might not necessarily
be that it's their goal to destroy the
system but they do want to enrich
themselves at the expense of everybody
else and they also want to hook their
friends up and demolish whatever part of
the culture it is that happens to bother
them and that's going to have
consequences that not even they realize
it's going to get really bad so let's
use the last few minutes for super chats
to talk about this technocratic
hellscape uh just have some fun because
earlier earlier today i went to this ai
and i asked it to make images of donald
trump joe biden nancy pelosi so we
pulled it up again and before the show i
asked this ai to generate some images
for me
and i'm going to show you these images
because they're hilarious and i hope you
guys enjoy them it's from the new avatar
movie yes so i said i would like to see
an image of tom cruise and this is what
it gave me folks are only listening you
know i it'll only be a few minutes but
i'll describe it it is an orange
background with a blue skinned man
that could kind of look like tom cruise
it's not adam driver jake dylan look at
this yeah it does
yeah yeah he's got a bunch of he's got
too many teeth
i mean kind of a babe though
he's like he's like a
you know model looking kind of guy all
right let's go to the next one i said
bill clinton all right you guys ready
for this here's ai it looks like guy
fieri he looked yeah about to take us to
flavor town
he said bill's about to go to flavor
town island on a private channel
right on a private jet
private island you guys ready for this
one an ai generated bill gates here we
go
i asked for that one i don't know what
this is yeah what's the bill portion of
that is it like saint peter it's like
the kremlin or something
it's not a person no because i don't
know who's next you guys ready jeffrey
epstein oh man you guys ready for ai
generated jeffrey epstein there you go
that's not right
i mean it's pretty close that's probably
what he looks like now after the
reconstructive facial surgery
they were trying to figure out how to
reconstruct a facial surgery so they ran
it through the ai and they made this
somewhere in the world right now there's
a guy looking exactly like that be like
they're on to me are you guys ready for
the best of this next one is the best
one is it donald trump jr
are you guys ready for this
i'm warning you now you guys are going
to lose it when you see an ai generated
donald trump jr you're ready for this
here you go
what on earth
it's the spoon that gets me it's got a
spoon it's it's okay first of all it it
looks more like alan west than donald
trump jr yeah it does for smooth skin
there's something wrong with the chin
but it is a black man with a spoon in
his mouth yeah i don't understand like a
sushi sashimi napkin bib uh just like
he's rich he was born with a silver
spoon in his mouth is that what we're
seeing i don't know i don't know how
this is are we sure we're not looking at
hunter biden's art i don't know this is
kind of what it looks like all right nah
this one you guys are this one might
scare the child this one's going to
scare the kids nancy pelosi yeah but she
always does yes yeah she does true
here's nancy pelosi
skin suit yet actually i think she looks
better here than she does in real life
it looks like a skin a nancy pelosi skin
suit look at that look at the eyes
there's like
what is this it's what is going on that
is so
creepy yeah
i will not be taking over anytime soon
all right all right now for the people
on the show you guys ready for a good
one
luke rydkowski is first yeah here is a i
generated luke rodkowski
sort of got the eyes right yeah yeah but
like the nose should be a lot bigger
it's like you and brandon ruth combined
probably yeah that i don't understand
like the hair is wrong like what it's
not bad this all right who's next adam
this is the next one the next one i
think is sheamus in about uh two years i
think it's me about you guys you guys
are gonna love sheamus you ready
you ready for sheamus famous in two
years
i can see it fat bastard i know i think
it looks kind of like me i really could
see it
i see it it looks
no but it's got like thanos's chin yeah
and joe biden
it's like joe biden and thanos yeah
exactly that's that's sheamus
uh who's next lydia lydia's was just
like an ai yes i look like the lady from
the closer and like one of your eyes is
smash creepy eyes yeah but this is kind
of weird because it just looks like it
just looks like a bad like a badly drawn
person no it looks like it looks like it
was
trying to disguise itself as well i know
it does yeah eyeballs and now for the
best one
timothy poole
are you guys ready for this
here we go it's literally a swimming
pool
that's what they that's what the ai made
the a.i literally just made a swimming p
i wish there was a beanie on it it's the
tiffany cool
just like bill gates if your name is a
common noun you cannot be ai generated
what if you put an e at the end so if
you if you follow my twitter
twitter.comtimcast you can see
where i
made an ai generated image of joe biden
sniffing a little girl
joe biden and donald trump fused
together as one person that's the worst
a couple of bonus joe bidens
yeah that was fun the joe biden sniffing
the little girl is my favorite but it's
like it's weird it's not it's it's just
his face is smashed and like there's not
really little girls like a weird
mashed-faced pig looking thing yeah i
won't be able to sleep tonight if you
show it again
i don't even want to see it again no
it's crazy it's on twitter
the nancy pelosi was good actually maybe
i can pull it up if i just go to twitter
go to my oh yeah you know what i'll just
i'll just i'll just pull it up here
we're on twitter let's see we got here
oh my god ai
joe biden sniffing a little girl ai
generated image what look at this
oh man so the ai created that image yes
you made it an a.i made this image wow
yeah
here's a couple of joe biden bonuses
it's melting
here's donald trump and joe about
infused as one person yep that's
actually pretty legit that one's good
it's pretty good here's nancy pelosi
dude why are her hands always weird in
this she looks great i don't know dude
she needs all the hands to hold all the
money she's getting from the stock
market that's true that's true here's
joe biden ai and then the donald trump
yeah what's with like his hand on his
shoulder like that happening
frankly
are you talking about me it's like they
were at the madam madam how do you say
that
and then it melted yeah that's not
exactly what it looks like
all right everybody i don't like that
that's uh that's ai but uh we're gonna
you should have the the ai um
draw a super chatter at some point
the ai what draw super chatter you know
right oh like one of their names or one
of their names but the issue the issue
is that unless they're really really
famous it just gives you random images
like i don't know i think i thought luke
and i looked pretty good you looked
pretty good too bro i was a swimming
pool yeah yeah exactly swimming pools
look great looking good yeah thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you